el coronavirus ha vuelto a mutar una
nueva variante fue detectada en japón en
cuatro viajeros que acababan de llegar
de brasil todavía no está claro que tan
contagiosa es la nueva variante pero se
sabe que tiene ciertas similitudes con
las variantes de reino unido y sudáfrica
el descubrimiento llega sólo unos días
después de que tokio impusiera el estado
de emergencia en respuesta al aumento de
casos hay toques de queda a las 8 de la
noche no obstante el tradicional día del
adulto en japon está previsto para el
lunes cuando se celebrará por aquellos
que cumplen 20 años aquí en kawasaki las
celebraciones tradicionales continuaron
a pesar de las normas soy muy consciente
del riesgo de contagio pero estoy aquí
porque es un evento que pasa una vez en
la vida y es una oportunidad para ver
amigos hay una atmósfera especial que
solo se puede sentir en el lugar y
realmente quería ponerme un kimono por
lo que decidí venir hoy eventos como
este no han sido explícitamente
prohibidos por el gobierno que sí
recomienda que la gente no se reúne en
grupos grandes el primer ministro dijo
que la gente joven está especial
en riesgo más de la mitad de los nuevos
contagios en tokio están entre menores
de 30 años